if there's any time in my life that it's
been more focused on my race it's only
once I started dating my husband Meghan
Markle making Royal confessions with
Mariah Carey Until Then I had been
treated like a mixed woman
and things really shifted but but that's
an interesting thing a mixed woman
because I always thought it should be
okay to say I'm mixed the singer is the
latest guest on Megan's archetypes
podcast and the two get real about
growing up biracial sharing how hard it
was to fit in I didn't fit in anywhere
at all I remember being in school in in
this predominantly white neighborhood
where my mom felt comfortable and I
tried my best to feel comfortable you
know I think for us it's so different
because we're light-skinned you're not
treated as a black woman you're not
treated as a white woman you sort of fit
in between then Megan who has a black
mother and a white father recalls how
her Blackness became such a focus when
she started dating her now husband
Prince Harry if there's any time in my
life that it's been more focused on my
race it's only once I started dating my
husband then I started to understand
what it was like to be treated like a
black woman because up until then I had
been treated like a mixed woman and
things really shifted but but that's an
interesting thing a mixed woman because
I always thought it should be okay to
say I'm mixed like it should be okay to
say that but people want you to choose
yes the Duchess of Sussex has been open
about the racism she experienced during
their time as senior working members of
the royal family the inference of course
it being one of those high-profile
senior members
is the question is racism at the heart
of the British Monarchy and that
experience contributed to Megan and
Harry's decision to step back from their
official roles in 2020. the sussexes
have made it clear they have no desire
to go back to the royal family they have
carved a new life themselves in
California it seems safe to say the
couples moved to California's inspired
Megan to reclaim her voice we'll have
plenty of the the famous articulate and
successful opinionated women that Megan
knows to make her podcast probably a
very successful debut the show's already
at the top of the Spotify charts
continuing to climb thanks to Megan's
candid confessions like this one about
what Mariah means to her as a biracial
woman I to talk to you of course I had
to talk to you you were so formative for
me
representation matters so much but when
you are a woman and you don't see a
woman who looks like you somewhere in a
position of power or influence or even
just on the screen because we know how
influential media is you came onto the
scene it's like oh my gosh
someone what someone kind of looks like
me did you feel like I know that this
person is like I Can Tell She's black
and white yeah like I Can Tell She's yes
I could feel that
foreign